think about what we learned last lesson
we thought about
statements of this format this is a
statement it can be true or false
but when you see there's something and
implies another
then this kind of statement is called an
because it's because it
implies it's an implication right so
when we have a look at these
implication statements we notice when we
looked at a whole bunch of different
examples of this right
if you know the implication is true
then there are some other things you can
know the truth or
falsity of for example
the negation of this the opposite of
this how would we write that in symbols
by the way you start with p right
and what it implies instead of q this is
the negation right it implies not q
right so we know that if your original
implication
is true then your negation must be false
but we also introduced this other weirdo
sounding thing the contrapositive
right which is written quite differently
it's got some bits in common
it also uses negation what does the
contra positive start with
not q
it leads to not p this is the
contrapositive
right you turn around backwards you
negate everything
and if you know the original implication
is true then what can you tell me about
the contrapositive
it must also be true
now just before we uh move forward to
think about the implications of this
which is what the
heading is for today it occurred to me
that even though i gave you some
examples of this in our like big
table right uh we didn't really sort of
go into much of a proof
of this idea the law of the
contrapositive that's actually what it's
called
so i'm going to give you a really quick
and dirty one which i hope is a little
more satisfying to you
you've always got to make sure when
someone tells you something you're not
just like
i read it somewhere someone told me i at
least have some logical
cogs that i can turn to reason why this
must be true okay
so maybe you want to draw this diagram
with me it is going to be excessively
simple
which is great i think it means it's
even though it's simple it does the job
okay
what would it look like how could we
diagrammatically represent represent
p implies q there's lots of different
ways right for instance
i could say i'm going to draw kind of
like
a wedo venn diagram looking thing this
is not actually a venn diagram for some
weird and technical reasons it's called
an euler diagram
but this diagram i'm going to try and
use to represent
if p is true then q absolutely must be
true okay
so imagine that this red circle is all
the possible
like versions of p right so when we're
talking about like
uh if it's raining then it's cold right
so it's like oh every possible rainy day
is in here okay now if p implies q
what we're saying is if you're in this
circle
you must necessarily be inside this one
where that represents all the
possibilities for
q all the different kinds of cold days i
guess right
so you can see here just from this very
simple diagram if you're in here
you must be in here do you agree with
that premise is that okay
now think about what the contrapositive
would mean in the context
of this diagram think about what not q
represents and what not p
represents now what i'm saying is
if you are not in this circle but
outside this circle this is not q do you
agree with that
okay if you're out here then there's no
possible way you could somehow muscle
into here do you see that
it's like i've been excluded from the
green circle let alone
the red circle do you see how this must
imply
this happy with that it starts to get a
bit confusing because you can see i've
got this if then statement
about if then statements so you know
you've got all these nested logic in
here but i hope
that's a clear enough diagram for you
you can see why it is the case
okay so we have the negation of an
implication we've got the
contra positive and each one of these
gives us a new mechanism
for proof you've actually encountered
one of these before
but we haven't dealt with it formally so
i'm going to deal with both of them
together because they're kind of
interconnected even though this
contrapositive idea is newer
i'm going to use it as our first one
because interestingly
it's much simpler so when you use the
contrapositive to prove something
it's called proof by contraposition
why would we do this well sometimes the
contrapositive
is much easier to work with than the
actual implication you started with so
i'm going to give you a quick
example let's see if we can prove
this particular implication if x cubed
is odd then i want to show
that x must also
be odd and even though i haven't stated
it um when you hear the language of
parity odd or even kind of implies what
we're talking about here is integers
might as well write down
okay how would you go about this i'm
just going to pause for a moment i've
kind of
spoiled a little bit how we are going to
do this but before i actually march it
out for you
have a think about how you would even
begin such
a proof how would you do this in a
direct
way we know things about oddness right
if you know a number is odd what can you
tell me about that number
okay what can we express in number two
and plus one with n velocity
fantastic so i could say there exists
some n out there right there exists
some value of n so long as it's an
integer
such that i could write x as 2 n plus 1
and that work or 2 n minus 1
doesn't really matter same same but
different so we know that that's a
property i can use
but then you start thinking about well
how do i then bring that into
a format that's useful right you can by
the way it's just
i hope you're sensing it somewhat
awkward isn't it right if you were to
write down
x cubed equals two n plus one what would
be your
next step right it's not like oh i can
factorize or i can cancel right
like i said have somewhat already shown
my hand here but now let's think about
what the contrapositive
of this would look like because if we
can prove that that's true
the contrapositive that necessarily
implies
the contrapositive is true if and only
if the original statement is true
so let's try this down right consider
the contrapositive you've always got to
explain what it is that you're doing
in the structure of a proof and even
though
it's not a very good um not very good
thing just to sort of like eyeball the
proof and say oh does this
like look like a reasonable proof when i
look at a proof and there are very few
words in it
it's kind of like a red flag for me i'm
like i already don't think this is going
to be very clear we've got lots of
symbols
okay but never forget the power of just
a few useful words
let me pause for a moment i've asked you
to consider this remember
if p implies q is the original statement
we need to
negate everything and switch the order
can you have a go
at writing what you think the
contrapositive of this statement is
have a shot liam what do you offer me
if x is even
so pause for a minute where's william
gotten this from
he started with this q you see that
right
and then he said well i want not q i
want the negation of that i pop that
right out the front
do you agree with that as not q happy
yeah
again dealing in integer land things are
either even or they're right fantastic
liam do you want to give me that second
part of the sentence again please then
wonderful thank you once you've kind of
got not cue not piece sort of falls out
you're like i've got no other pieces to
work with here
okay this is what we are going to set
out to prove and i wonder if you can see
why for two reasons at least this is
much nicer to handle
than this even if neither is possible
impossible right
firstly we said before um joe hopefully
mentioned this is how you would state an
odd number
right how do you state an even number
just 2m
right uh here
which you're going to write down formula
in a second just out of the gate right
you're like oh
2n is a nicer thing to deal with than 2m
plus 1
right i mean it's not much of a
difference right now but you cube things
and you're like oh gross
i would rather not have to deal with
something like this if i can help it
right
that's the first thing the second thing
is the structure of this right what we
call the
antecedent what comes first and the
consequent what comes later
right we're going from something simpler
to something complicated and our brains
are just much better at handling that
it's why when i asked you before if you
wrote down x cubed equals two n plus one
your brain is kind of like huh wait
what's the next right
so i think you might already have the
wheels turning here can someone help me
out
how am i i write the very first line
here i've just written the quantum
positive but how do i begin my proof
what we've done we've introduced a way
to say x because we're saying it's even
this is the premise we're beginning with
and of course we have to specify what
kind of number n is
and then we say well if this is what x
is i can immediately and quite simply
think about what x
cubed is i can say therefore x cubed
would be equal to
in this case don't skip anything this is
2m or
cubed and remember where i'm trying to
head is
that x cubed is even which means i can
factorize out that too so
weirdly i'm going to expand this out
like halfway
i just want to pull out one of the twos
that's all i really need right once i've
got that
anything that follows as long as it's
integer is fine and the thing that
follows is this
do you agree with that ta-da i can say
well therefore
this implies x cubed is even
okay and that's what i set out to prove
we're pretty much there do you see how
marvelously straightforward that was
versus like is your brain still ticking
over how you would have gone about it in
a direct way
i should conclude i can say by the
contrapositive
and then i would end with the original
statement right i've clearly established
the contrapositive is true so therefore
the original implication x cubed
is odd implies
it's kind of neat right okay